[Music]
love that music time to talk NFL
playoffs the race is heating up four
weeks to go in the regular season and a
big matchup is Sunday's game between the
Cincinnati Bengals and the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers kickoff set for 4 25 p.m
eastern time and you can watch it right
here on CBS both teams vying for playoff
positions and joining us now for more on
all of it CBS Sports Jim Nance lead
play-by-play announcer for the NFL on
CBS Jim good morning uh simple question
good morning friends what are you
looking for good morning good morning
well good morning hey Gail Vlad it's
just hearing the music gets me fired up
on an early Friday morning I'm on my way
to I'm on my way to Tampa right after
this hit but look we all know Tom
Brady's 45 this has not been the season
of his dreams but they still lead their
division and while you have a chance to
watch the greatest of all time you want
to watch and they're coming off a pretty
humiliating loss at San Francisco last
weekend going against a team that won
the AFC and went to the Super Bowl last
year so we've got a really good matchup
coming up on Sunday afternoon
yeah match up uh Jim we're talking Joe
burrow and Tom Brady going head-to-head
of course Tom Brady as you just said one
of the greatest of all time but uh not
too shabby himself is quarterback Joe
burrow what are you expecting
well I think that Joe
first off he's in that very upper
echelon Elite quarterback status
uh people call him because he's named
Joe the Joe cool they compare him to Joe
Montana but I think he had to like
really compare him to a to a legendary
quarterback I think his style play would
be more similar to Tom Brady there's a
go between Kevin Falco used to be with
the Patriots it was a coach down at LSU
when Joe was there said the similarities
are almost Eerie and uh listen Joe is
just a young kid in his mid-20s he's
already gone to a Super Bowl and
sometimes maybe he gets even a little
bit lost with the Patrick Mahomes and
Josh Allens and now what Jalen hurts is
doing but Joe is in the discussion for
MVP this year and this team in
Cincinnati is on a roll he won five in a
row
it is a guessing game of the season as
you know Jim with all the stuff that Tom
Brady's had on and off the field how
much longer is he going to play when is
he going to retire do you think he's
sick of this conversation and this
question
and that said what's your team
inquiring minds want to know uh I think
I think Tom
is probably down to his last year I'm
not going to ever rule him out it's like
when tiger was not playing if people
said he'll never win again of course he
came back and won so the truly great
ones and he's he's one of the all-time
greats you don't ever say they're not
going to be capable of doing something
but it just this has not been the kind
of season that he hoped for and it's not
because his level of play is off in fact
his numbers statistically are great
there are other issues uh around around
this team physical issues with this team
but can he continue to take being under
the media Spotlight listen when you've
won as many Super Bowls as Tom has he
this is his life he lives it everything
he does is highly watched and
scrutinized so he's pretty immune to it
I think but he's human you know he's a
he's a dad who is a great dad and he's a
faithful son to his mom and dad and does
uh everything I believe tries to do
everything the right way and I know he
would like to whenever that day comes
with this is it I think he'd like to end
this career in style that would be in
the postseason and making a run of the
postseason and listen the Bucks are six
and seven but they lead their division
they're probably going to be in the
postseason if you don't want to face him
when it comes playoff time that's for
sure no no you don't he's got a pretty
good record I appreciate it Joe bro's
comments about the matchup with Tom
Brady asked about it he said well he's
Tom and I'm Joe which is accurate we'll
see how it all plays on on Sunday Jim
Nance thank you very much coverage of
the NFL starts at new noon Eastern right
here on CBS you can catch the Bengals
Bucks game along with the Full Slate of
game starting at 1pm up next Mr GTA will
be giving us all the things we want to
talk about today talk at the table
coming up wait no what's a watch I want
to watch bro get The Branding right I
was looking over at you and I'm all
thrown off Tony do you want this job
football on Sunday that's a Klaus line
coming up